denn noch bis morgen trifft sich die
afd-bundestagsfraktion zu einer
Klausurtagung in Oberhof Ziel ist der
Erarbeitung eines Positionspapier mit
alternativen zur ampelregierung so
schreibt es die AFD in ihrer
Pressekonferenz sagten die Vorsitzenden
kropalla und Weidel
man hat mittlerweile das Gefühl dass es
dieser Regierung nicht schnell genug
gehen kann dieses Land Platz zu machen
und vor die Wand zu fahren es sind
völlig irrsinnige
Gesetzesvorhaben auf dem Weg gebracht
und wir sehen von dieser Regierung
überhaupt gar keine lösungsperspektiven
auch die CDU geriert sich als
oppositionsverweigerer und
dementsprechend ist auch dort keine
Lösung zu erwarten wir haben uns
zur Aufgabe gemacht die Idee
Industrialisierung Deutschlands sofort
zu stoppen sollten wir in der
Regierungsverantwortung sein
die Energiekosten sind deutlich zu hoch
aus dem Grunde würden wir sofort dass
EEG kassieren wir würden dafür sorgen
dass eine Energiepolitik verantwortlich
betrieben wird sie Technologie offen ist
und dazu gehört natürlich zur
Sofortmaßnahme die bestehenden
Kernkraftwerke die anschaltbar sind das
sind nämlich die letzten die
abgeschaltet wurden sofort wieder im
Betrieb zu nehmen und neue
Kernkraftwerke auch mit neueren
Technologien zu bauen das wird alles
nicht gemacht Deutschland stützt sich
auf flatterstrom auf die erneuerbaren
Energien wie sie so genannt werden das
sind sie natürlich mitnichten die immer
noch ein einstelligen
Prozentsatz des Energiemixes hier
ausmachen und für diese völlig verrückt
gewordene grüne Regierung ist es völlig
in Ordnung wie ist der
Vizekanzler und Wirtschafts- und
Energieminister gesagt hat das ist
völlig in Ordnung ist aus der Ukraine
Strom auch mit zu importieren und das
ist völlig in Ordnung ist für die
Ukraine dass Sie Ihre alten
Atomkraftwerke am Laufen halten weil sie
sein ja schließlich rothen gebaut worden
da frage ich mich wirklich was dieser
Wirtschafts- und Energieminister
eigentlich im Sinn hat er schaltet die
modernsten
Kernkraftwerke ab in Deutschland und
will andere
hochgefährdete Meiler laufen lassen das
werden wir sobald wir in der
Regierungsverantwortung sind abstellen
denn wir brauchen ein vernünftigen
Energiemix und natürlich die Kernkraft
die dazugehört um diese horrenden
Energiekosten abzustellen und wieder zu
senken denn wir preisen uns aus dem
Markt heraus die Unternehmen heute
leiden unter diesen Energiekosten und
Sie müssen sich vorstellen dass
Energiekosten in der Wertschöpfungskette
in jedem Produkt drin stecken darum
werden alle Produkte teurer das wird ja
auch seltens verstanden dieser Sache
Zusammenhang dass das vielleicht auch
etwas mit der Inflation zu tun haben mit
der wir uns heute konfrontiert sehen
als wir vor zwei Jahren noch weit vor
dem Krieg in der Ukraine davon
gesprochen haben dass sich Deutschland
gerade mit dieser Energiepolitik auf dem
Weg in die Industrie Industrialisierung
macht der würde das als
Verschwörungstheorie abgetan und als
Angstmacherei mittlerweile erleben wir
das selbst große Tageszeitungen
selbst von der die Industrialisierung
sprechen mit der BDI Chef ebenso bereits
davor waren vor einer toxischen
Situation wird gesprochen und dann
erlebe ich Herrn Scholz gestern in
Meseberg und er tritt vor die Presse und
spricht davon dass die Preise sinken und
freut sich darüber aktueller Gaspreis
ich habe mir das auch heute extra noch
mal angeguckt bis zum 30 September der
Altverträge die Kilowattstunde 5,3 Cent
wir haben aktuell Angebote von 9,7 Cent
die Kilowattstunde Gas das sind ein ist
ein Preiszuwachs von 81 Prozent der noch
kommt also wir sind noch lange nicht am
Ende der
Fahnenstange genau das gleiche trifft
auf Strom zu wo wir im Jahr 2016 noch
Kilowatt Preise von 11 Cent die
Kilowattstunde hatten mittlerweile sind
wir bei 44 45 Cent die Kilowattstunde
auch für die Industrie das bedeutet also
eine Preisanstieg von über 200% und das
ist vollkommen klar dass sie natürlich
dann die große Industrie auch die
Industrie was Glas angeht was Stahl
angeht was Eisen angeht Keramik das Land
fluchtartig verlassen und das sind ja
bereits mittlerweile über 40%, die
aufgepackten Koffern stehen und dieses
Land auch verlassen wollen
Professor Frank Decker wenn sie mal den
Faktencheck im Kopf anwerfen wie
dramatisch sehen Sie diese Situation
wirklich
nun wir haben tatsächlich in diesem Jahr
minuswachstum zu erwarten also und auch
im europäischen Vergleich Deutschland
ist das wirtschaftsstärkste Land in
Europa in der Europäischen Union und das
hat natürlich mit Dingen zu tun die in
der Vergangenheit
stattgefunden haben nämlich die starke
Energieabhängigkeit von Russland die
starke Exportabhängigkeit insbesondere
in Richtung China und natürlich auch die
Tatsache dass wir uns sehr auf die
Amerikaner verlassen haben was unsere
eigene Sicherheit angeht und die mit dem
spätestens mit dem Ukraine kriegt sind
all diese Pfeiler auch des deutschen
Wohlstands und der günstigen Entwicklung
die wir hatten in den letzten zehn
Jahren die sind brüchig geworden und sie
sind hierzulande eben brüchiger als in
anderen der europäischen Ländern wir
sind eben jetzt in der Situation dass
wir diese
ökologische Transformation den Umbau des
Industrie- und des Energiesystems eben
auch sehr viel schneller
bewerkstelligen müssen und das birgt
natürlich sehr große
Konflikte eigentlich sollte man ja auch
von einer
sozialökologischen Transformation
sprechen weil es dort auch gerecht
zugehen sollte in der Gesellschaft was
auch die Verteilung der damit
verbundenen Lasten angeht und hier hat
die AFD natürlich jetzt leichtes Spiel
etwa die steigenden
Energiekosten zu thematisieren sie würde
ja am liebsten beim Klimaschutz dann
auch auf die Bremse treten nur damit
werden wir die Ziele die wir uns ja
selber gesetzt haben nicht erreichen
also wir müssen das beides miteinander
in Einklang bringen und
insoweit Recht es sich dass wir diesen
Transformationsprozess nicht schon
wesentlich früher angegangen sind also
insoweit muss jetzt auch die jetzige
Regierung und egal welche es gewesen
wäre die Probleme aufarbeiten die sich
eben in der Vergangenheit aufgehäuft
haben die AFD hat im Grunde zwei
gewinnerthemen sie braucht selber gar
keine konstruktive denn
Alternativen anzubieten trotz ihres
Partei namens Alternative für
Deutschland das reicht wenn sie da
antipositionen vertritt das ist der
Klimaschutz auf der einen Seite und auf
der anderen Seite das ist eben nicht
angesprochen worden aber es ist
natürlich das Thema Migration was jetzt
auch wieder eine größere Rolle spielt
und auch das spielt natürlich der AFD in
die Hände wenn sie dort einfach nur
antipositionen vertritt das ist
sicherlich der Hauptgrund für die jetzt
doch sehr starken Umfragewerte was muss
die Ampel dem entgegensetzen
die Ampeln muss
Lösungen entgegensetzen aber sie muss
natürlich auch anders auftreten also das
Bild einer zerstrittenen Koalition wo
selbst getroffene Beschlüsse
nachträglich wieder in Frage gestellt
werden damit wird man in der
Öffentlichkeit nicht punkten können es
spricht nichts dagegen dass auch die
unterschiedlichen Parteien ihre
unterschiedlichen Positionen deutlich
machen auch öffentlich deutlich machen
nur wenn man sich verständigt hat wenn
man auch Kompromisse gemacht hat muss
man diese Kompromisse dann auch
gemeinsam als Team nach außen hin
vertreten und daran hat es in der ganzen
letzten Zeit gemangelt Professor Frank
Decker von der Bonner Universität vielen
Dank
dass Sie begleitet haben vielen Dank für
ihre Einordnung